ils ont énormément de questions à vous
poser bien évidemment thibault en
premier alors j'ai un petit soucis parce
que je me souviens jamais de mes rêves
se sauve ce qui concerne madame jalouse
caroline ithurbide mais ça c'est autre
chose mais en général je ne me souviens
jamais de mes rêves le matin est ce que
c'est inquiétant
est ce que c'est parce que j'ai la
mémoire courte ou est ce que c'est parce
que vous parliez d'inconscient est-ce
que l'inconscient a bloqué parce qu'il
ya des choses inavouables chez thibault
alors ça peut être effectivement un
problème de censure de blocage où ça
peut être un problème d'activité vous
êtes trop en activité vous n'avez pas le
temps de vous intéresser au contenu du
rêve blocage donc il ya deux
possibilités quand on ne se souvient pas
de son rêve c'est soit votre inconscient
qui ne veut pas que ça remonte à la
surface
soit c'est parce qu'on travaille trop il
ya une activité qui est tellement
intense qu'on n'a pas besoin de
s'intéresser à son général des hommes se
souvient de moins bien de leurs
parcelles raison ça les femmes sont plus
en relation avec leur inconscient il
s'intéresse beaucoup plus au
fonctionnement psychologique d'accord
qu'il faut s'inquiéter si on si on s'il
se dit finalement je suis pas j'ai pas
une activité débordante donc ça veut
dire que je bloque quelque chose si je
ne me souviens pas de mes rêves parce
qu'il faut s'en inquiéter
oui il a l'air d'être en bonne santé
donc je ne pense pas moi je trouve ça un
petit peu dommage parce que c'est une
seconde vie grenat et donc c'est
intéressant de savoir ce qui s'y passe
et on nous dit parfois qu'il est que
c'est intéressant de d'avoir un petit
calepin près de la table de chevet sur
la table de chevet pour noter au réveil
pour pas que ça disparaisse ça c'est
l'apport là puisque le rêve est très
évanescent donc quand on se réveille
évidemment ça va se disperser dans la
journée un petit carnet ou alors
maintenant le téléphone avec le
dictaphone et tout de suite on a le mot
clé d'accord emilie également un car moi
je rêve souvent que je perds mes dons
c'est vrai mais ça c'est si bien sont
pas très belle et propre à de nombreuses
personnes non malades souvent c'est dans
ces types de rêve donc ça ne veut pas
dire que quelqu'un va mourir puisque ça
c'est la croyance populaire tandis
armoiries non parce que la démo rien là
tous les jours donc on peut toujours les
mettre en relation non ça veut juste
dire vous êtes en surmenage a que le
cerveau anticipe ce qui est de se
produire vous allez par trop de stress
ou trop de fatigue menacer votre appétit
de vivre vos dents et vous allez devenir
une perdant
très bien c'est pour ça qu'elle va nous
dire qu'elle est trop fatigué pour
travailler donc justement le message du
rêve est là pour dire attention même si
on ne comprend pas consciemment on peut
s'inquiéter l'accord des soudures je
vais faire attention attendu patronne
oui tout à fait les dents égale
surcharge de travail surmenage et
c'était toujours il faut toujours mettre
le rêve en relation et grotesque du
rêveur évidemment mais d'une façon
simple les pertes de danse ont toujours
lié à une perte de vitalité a très bien
d'accord ok ok pourtant elle a une
grosse patate ans mais bon alors moi je
vais énormément et la semaine dernière
de quoi je rêve
valérie benaïm ici présentes arrivait
sur ce plateau ça ressemblait vraiment à
ça devant voilà ce public elle était nue
détendue c'est à dire effectivement plus
à massa m'a étonné voilà la pudeur de la
personne et il y avait une décontraction
totale et elle présentait l'émission
d'absa leurs geôliers de m'habiller bon
c'est pas grave ça c'est très moyen et
toi faut nous le dire oui la date peur
de jouer bien sûr va vous pensez bien
pour que nous suivons la rêvait de sa
patronne lui je sais pas il ya peut-être
un trailer dans un premier temps je vais
me dire quelque chose mais pas sur le
prend au premier degré
si c'est vraiment valérie qui
représentait ça veut dire qu'elle se met
à nu devant tout le monde c'est à dire
que se montre exactement comme elle est
vraie faria pas de masque je vais lire
le présent qu'elle est par contre très
souvent les des personnes morales sur
des projection de soi même ça va être à
poil
[Rires]
vous mettez en vous faites de la télé
que valérie blum était venu aussi bas on
est dans une relation de confiance et on
se dit les choses
ah ben c'est plutôt l'opposition alors
tout ça j'aime beaucoup et peut pas le
faire au centre moi je voudrais bien et
non mais en tout cas la nudité c'est
vrai que c'est aussi une thématique qui
est assez récurrente dans les rêves
on se retrouve nue dans la dans la rue
ou bienvenue à une conférence ou autre
ce qui veut dire qu'à ce moment là c'est
une façon c'est quelqu'un qui on redoute
ou est heureux de dévoiler le tout
simplement c'est qu'on sait on s'est mis
à nu d'accord quelques fois le rêve peut
être vécu avec angoisse tout d'un coup
on se rend compte qu'on nous on est nu
et on devient de plus en plus mal à
l'aise ça ça veut dire qu'on s'est mis à
genoux devant les autres et qu'ils ne
sont pas prêts d'accord c'est à dire
qu'il ya un jugement qui est derrière et
là bon il a visiblement des corps
n'étant le monde est prêt pour me voir à
poil d'accord très bien moi c'est plus
plombe haut rhin à voir c'est dans un
rêve je perds mes yeux j'ai plus deuil
je les ai dans ma main j'essaye de les
remettre et je n'arrive pas à les
remettre
et je dis je dis régulièrement sur reims
sur instagram et twitter espère que je
vous aime infiniment tous mais que je
travaillais qu'une bande de tarés
[Applaudissements]
ne détruisez pas un individu qui va bien
c'est de façon simple c'est que la
prunelle de mes yeux il ya donc quelque
chose qui est en rapport avec une valeur
que vous avez que vous perdez que vous
avez le sentiment sur le sentiment
seulement de perdre c'est plus quelque
chose qui a de la valeur qui vient
chaque plan même en danger
on pourrait rapprocher sa au rêve de
perte de dents alors c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus rare
revient ma fille s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]